foreign
[Music]
here are all the 13 kaijus and alien
monsters that appeared in shooting
Ultraman in my opinion one of the best
monster movies from Japan in a long time
with top-notch monster designs so let's
get to it the first one Gomez Gomez was
the first Kaiju to arrive on Earth
during the mass appearance of these
gigantic monsters Breaking Free from a
mine Gomez then engaged in combat with
the jsdf the Japan self-defense forces
but was killed by a tank Detachment
emptying its ammunition on him in this
movie Gomez is a modified Godzilla 4th 4
model from the 2016 film Shin Godzilla
just the design it appeared to be more
armored with extra plates on his body
and a tailor possesses a secondary mouth
full of sharp teeth it's back is lined
with dorsal plates and his head
possesses three horns Gomez here is 40
meters or 130 feet in height
the second one nironga niranga is a gray
armored Kaiju with two rows of yellow
plates running down its back and also
spines bursting from the gaps between
them he has a large mouth with bright
red gums and lips and a plethora of
little teeth and photos it also
possesses beady eyes with short pupils
two insectoid mandible like antlers and
a single golden nasal horn decorated top
of its head naronga has an orange patch
on his neck and five fingered hands with
extended claws on each thumb it feeds on
and can fire electric Rays can also
become invisible and is 40 to 50 meters
or 130 to 165 feet in height the third
one gabora also known as S-Class species
number eight Gabor appeared as a near
unkillable monster for the military
since gabora is a Subterranean Kaiju it
possesses Frills which can be closed to
form a drill the drill is used by it to
travel underground to Radioactive
sources to feed on gaboro is quadrupedal
in nature with a heavily armored skin
and a round head with multiple eyes and
clothes in this massive drill it also
has two long tails which also act and
are designed as drills it can also fire
a deadly radioactive beam despite being
quadrupedal when it stands on two feet
its height is close to 70 meters or 230
feet
the fourth one the mammoth flower this
is actually the second Kaiju life found
that appeared and was dealt with by the
Japan self-defense forces it was known
as the mammoth flower because it looks
like a flower and it was mammoth in size
it sprung out from the earth in central
Tokyo flowering in front of the Tokyo
Station the jsdf vanquished the mammoth
flower and caused it to wilt after
employing a mixture of carbon dioxide
gas and fire it was 100 meters or 328
feet in height
the fifth one big wheeler this kaju
named piguila is one of the many S-Class
species to appear in Japan paguila
emerged in the suburbs of a city that
had frozen over due to its abilities it
appears as a vaguely reptilian bipedal
monster with two toss on its mouth and
four limbs with bladed feathers as Wings
it is later killed by the Japanese
military after a female scientist
uncovered its weakness which we do not
know it can create a freezing Miss
around where it is and it stands 40
meters or 130 feet in height
number six the larrugus the fourth giant
monster to appear in Japan the rookies
flew through the grounds of the Kumamoto
Castle kicking up great clouds of dust
and debris with each beat of its wings
the rugeus appears as a gigantic bird
with white feathers and a red beak it
possesses an unknown stealth technique
that allows it to evade detection
allowing him to avoid being detected
after his initial appearance in Kumamoto
it was stated to be 50 meters or 165
feet in height
number seven geigel also stated as a
hostile giant unknown Live Form number
five or a dissolving S-Class species it
was the fifth Kaiju to appear and attack
Japan it appears as a gigantic land
snail with a massive shell on its back
the shell is multi-colored and has spiky
outgrowths here and there its eyes are
luminescent or bioluminescent and are
placed on stalks on the top of its head
this Kaiju is the smallest here as it is
only 20 meters or 65 feet tall
number 8 pagus pagus was the sixth Kaiju
to surface in Japan and wreak havoc
appearing from underground the creature
feeds on nuclear substances and
radioactive ways and it had the ability
to fire a radioactive beam Packers is
quadrupedo in nature with a yellow
armored back and grayscales as well as
having a very long tail it has a round
head and multiple eyes however the
military was able to kill it with a lot
of effort but the radiation left behind
by its corpse caused a great deal of
damage and a large area to be off limits
Packers was 30 meters or 100 feet tall
number nine Shin Ultraman a being from
the planet of light ultraman's physique
is fully metallic silver and with
Crimson Parts the silver is said to be
solid spacium whereas the Crimson
sections are biological Ultraman has two
oval shaped eyes that glow when it is
awake and also full of energy ultraman's
physique is humanoid and he spots a
dorsal fin that extends almost all the
way down his back he stands 60 meters or
200 feet tall and is the main star of
the show obviously ultramanic Sultan had
to hand combat and can also fight ranged
attacks like the spacing beam from his
hand and the energy dust
number 10 zofi Here's the final
antagonist in the movie he's of the same
size and design as Ultraman except that
he is yellowish golden in color as they
are both from the same planet and being
members of the same species zofi
appeared in the end of the battle
between mephilis and Ultraman hellbent
on destroying the solar system to avoid
humans being weaponized by the beta
system by other alien species in the
Multiverse this form of zofi is more
ethically dubious regarding the death of
one sentient life form or a species
among the billions in the Galaxy as
inconsequential and not above genocide
so zofi here is more of a morally gray
character from the planet of light
number 11 zarup a member of a race of
aliens from planet Zara of the same name
it is well talented at creating
Illusions zarup and its species have
been mostly portrayed as wild beings
with the desire to destroy other worlds
either through trickery or deception he
is best remembered for being the first
alien to imitate an ultra which he also
did again here in Shin Ultraman in order
to frame the ultra here zarab is seen as
a two-dimensional metallic entity with
segmented scaly skin and faux bluish dot
eyes
number 12 mephilis mephilis was
seemingly the third alien to appear in
planet Earth after zarab and Ultraman
but according to him however he was in
fact the first alien on Earth he had
been keeping an eye on the human race
and Earth for a while orchestrating all
the Kaiju related events so it is his
grand scheme of things that led to
Ultraman fusing with a human and
breaking his code his appearance like
zarup was Black Metallic with a frill
almost smooth interlocking Muffler
covering the neck region and also his
Jazz he was metallic in structure that's
it he was able to grow to a height of 60
meters or 200 feet to battle with
Ultraman over control of the beta system
technology
and lastly zidane zidden is considered
to be the most powerful monster in the
Ultraman series and made many
appearances however more powerful Kaiju
over time have appeared though numerous
stronger forms of Zidane have also been
introduced as well here in Shin Ultraman
it appeared as a massive robotic super
weapon that orbits the earth preparing
to destroy the entire solar system with
its weapon having a destructive range of
light years across its size alone would
be in the kilometers or miles in scale
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on Shin Ultraman Sky juice and
alien monsters do hit the like button
for support and subscribe but most of
all smash that Bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam